hey what's up this is dr john delony and
we are back
all right today we are talking about
overeating
overspending and is this anxiety or is
it something else
i got a great email from ask john
ramseysolutions.com
let's dive in here we go hi john what's
up it's great to talk to you
i enjoy listening to you and dave on the
dave ramsey show and i respect your
advice
i'm a single mom divorced for four years
now i've been
binge watching dave's show because i
want to change my future for myself and
my kids
good for you man my problem is that i've
amassed 70 000 in debt and i've gained
nearly 60 pounds because i find myself
dealing with anxiety by shopping or
eating it's a common response there
let's keep reading
to give you a very brief background i've
spent a lot of time praying and soul
searching and i've come to understand
that memories from my childhood
are the reasons i am struggling maybe
then because my parents didn't like me
much i was so
desperate for a family that i married
badly my ex-husband is very spiteful so
i'm still paying for that mistake
instead of just letting go of my past i
start feeling sorry for myself and i end
up
shopping or eating my parents were
alcoholics so i guess this is how i've
self-medicated
my head knows this is a stupid behavior
there is a lot there so stay tuned
now that i understand what is wrong with
me i want to start changing these
behaviors so i don't continue
burying myself in debt and being
overweight i cannot afford counseling
because i have put us too far into debt
already and i know it's time for me to
toughen up and pull myself together
i'm scared of failure because i know i
still spend way too much time
every day dreaming that i will meet
someone who loves me and i will
understand that spending so much time
focusing on the negative things will
lead to more of the bad behaviors i'm
trying to break
i am reading dave's book and i've
started working dave's baby steps and
i'm trying not to eat outside of
scheduled times
i really feel like i need to learn new
habits to replace the bad ones
so i don't slip back into my old ways
besides dave's baby steps what other
things can i do to replace my bad
habits i really appreciate any advice
you can give me thank you for the advice
and for all the hard work
you and the other personalities are
doing sincerely
z whew there's a lot
there okay so stand by we're going to go
through this hurricane style and i'm
going to walk alongside you on this one
here we go so when i read this email
without knowing anything else about you
i don't hear anxiety i don't hear panic
attacks
i don't hear depression i hear complete
and total loneliness disconnection
all by yourself even though you've got
an ex-husband
even though you're working even though
you've got kids and people around you
you're totally disconnected and we try
to solve this connection through eating
too much through spending too much
through
working out too much through working too
much through drugs through alcohol
through sleeping around any number of
different behaviors
it's all searching searching searching
for connection
and value and worth if you're the child
of an alcoholic
you probably struggle with trust issues
with
what i call fixing it issues where
you're always trying to fix everything
for everybody else
and you leave your issues just flailing
in the wind and you struggle from
peacekeeping issues
where you're always worried about other
people's feelings how they're doing how
are you
you okay i'm sorry honey what can i do
for
and you take your feelings and your
needs and you just
shove them down and you wake up one day
on the heels
of a broken marriage you're still not
connected to your family
you don't have any close close friends
that you can be totally vulnerable with
and you find yourself totally alone okay
so you said two things
that i want to ring the bell on number
one you said my head knows it's the
stupid behavior
i've got the knowledge in here right
i've read the right books
listened to the podcast watched the
right tv show and
gotten lectured by that old guy like you
know intellectually
right you know you shouldn't be eating
another pizza
right or whatever it is for you and you
know that you shouldn't be spending
things in your click click click click
click
you know that right you've acknowledged
it congratulations the second thing you
said i want to ring the bell on
is this i just need to toughen up and
pull myself together
right because that's what
individualistic people do
we get the right information we get our
heads right and then we get tough
and strong and we fight it and in the
short term that works
you can grind out a new workout program
and lose a bunch of weight
you can jump on the baby steps even and
just follow
the steps lock stock and barrel and
you're going to get out of debt
and all of those different things work
in the short term
it's just punting addictions it's just
moving the addiction to a new thing
you can get addicted to data and
addicted to a new podcast and addicted
to more information
or you can get addicted to trying to
solve it through muscle
and bone and grit or
you can submit to loneliness you can
submit to grieving
that you had alcoholic parents that
didn't show up for you
it sucks and they didn't teach you how
to love and they didn't teach you how to
be loved
you can submit to the loss of your
marriage
in here you blame your parents you blame
your upbringing for some of your adult
decisions
this happened so that's why i did this
there may be some truth to that but i
want you to put that aside
i want you to put that aside because the
adult decisions you're making now
are choices you're choosing to make or
not make it's just that simple
so what do you do right now number one
when folks in your situation
tell me i can't afford counseling right
now
i've put us too far in debt and i can't
afford counseling what i'm going to tell
you is you can't afford
not to have a professional with you
right now
if not a professional at least somebody
walking alongside you who's a mentor
who you can be vulnerable with you can
be open with right so i want to
encourage you
look for low cost community counseling
centers in your area
possibly see if there are graduate
students looking for internships
online low-cost counseling just so you
can get with somebody to bounce some
ideas off
so they can give you homework
assignments they're going to be specific
for you
and they're going to hold you
accountable to getting them done or
get with a pastor at your local church
get with a woman
who is about 10 years older than you
that maybe has been through divorce
maybe an al-anon group in your local
community a 12-step group in your local
community
get with somebody some group of people
that can walk alongside you in this
process
you cannot do this alone and that leads
me number two
i can give you a bunch of exercises and
a bunch of things you can do
like exercising and breathing and
meditating and gratitude journal i can
give you all those things
and walk you through a specific program
but back to number one
none of this works if your brain and
your heart and your spirit are
crying out for connection and you're
trying to solve that through achievement
and checklists so i want you to make it
your life's
mission to find some sort of group that
you can have a group of people with you
that will walk through
this journey with you i'm also going to
send you
a free copy of financial peace
university i'm going to put you through
financial peace university on our dime
and i want you to go through those steps
with that group you're going to be in an
online fpu class
financial peace university class and i
want you to use that accountability
group
i want you to get to know those folks
you're only going to be doing it
digitally but i want you to get to know
those folks
i want you to connect with them and i
want you to follow the baby steps
in order with the group all nine steps
and you all can celebrate your victories
and your stumbling
together as a community as we are
designed to do
i love this question if you will get
with a group
you will get some people in your life
and you will begin to learn how to
connect
and it's going to take months and it's
going to take years if you will connect
i'm confident that you'll get on the
road to being well
finding love again finding peace
forgiveness
and the most important thing of all
joy and worth in your self
so thanks for being with us again this
is dr john deloney with ramsay network
subscribe if you go to john delorean.com
you can read my latest article on
anxiety
and check out my anxiety checklist send
this to your friends
to your grandma and if your pet can read
send it to them too
talk to you later